bovey tracey tennis club the club now
has coaching in place for all ages from
three years upwards and now has over 100
members the Tennis Club achieved their
goal of becoming an accredited club by
getting Club mark status from the Lawn
Tennis Association which was awarded to
the BTT see recently a coach from Bobby
Tracey tennis club now helps at local
schools in the area delivering tennis
coaching sessions to their students the
club also achieved some success recently
by getting a couple of players in the
top eight in the fly be player standings
Newton Abbot athletics club the club
showed their commitment to the sport and
progression within it by receiving Club
mark accreditation in June this year the
club also has a number of
high-performing participants that are
placed in UK Athletics rankings the
performers include Molly canim under-13s
ranked number one in the UK for 800
meters and the mile Martha Neil
under-23s ranked seventh in the
steeplechase and Gary smart v50 ranked
fourth in the 2k steeplechase team
Southwest octopus club octopus is an egg
latarian sport with girls competing with
boys as equals in mixed teams the
octopus club is extremely keen to
promote the sport as inclusive making
this more accessible to other
participants such as senior citizens the
club has achieved some fantastic results
in the last 12 months and also had eight
people from the club representing great
britain at age levels in the summer at
the Transworld tournament in Wales